[Aplausos]
fue el primer ministro que más tiempo
estuvo en el cargo en la historia de
japón amado y despreciado a la vez por
su política nacionalista y férrea el
mandato de shinzo abe estuvo marcado por
su plan para impulsar la economía
japonesa avn o mix
también ayudó a japón a superar el
devastador tsunami y el desastre nuclear
de fukushima en 2020 cuando renunció
debido a su mala salud se disculpó por
no haber podido permanecer más tiempo
tengo que responder ante la opinión
pública y no estoy dispuesto a continuar
mi mandato elegido por primera vez en
2006 abed emitió en 2007 debido a una
enfermedad crónica tras sólo un año en
el cargo pero luego en 2012 su partido
liberal-democrático de derechas obtuvo
una victoria arrolladora y volvió al
poder nieto y sobrino de primeros
ministros e hijo de un ministro de
asuntos exteriores a ver procede de una
rica y poderosa dinastía política
educado en estados unidos fue elogiado
por ayudar a la tercera economía del
mundo a encontrar su lugar en la escena
internacional
como fuerte defensor del fortalecimiento
militar ave intentó sin éxito modificar
la constitución pacifista de japón de la
posguerra a la luz de las disputas
territoriales
protegemos con nuestras propias manos
las hermosas aguas que rodean las islas
en gato no deberíamos mostrar nuestra
determinación de hacerlo la carrera
política de ave también ha sido
criticada por sus constantes errores sus
escándalos de corrupción sus promesas
fallidas cómo elevar el papel de la
mujer en japón y su gestión del
coronavirus recordado por su
nacionalismo ave también aportó
estabilidad al gobierno japonés con su
mandato ininterrumpido de 8 años como
primer ministro